[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to other installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing both the harry potter
and fantastic beasts franchises as well
as old voldemort and his trusty
companion
nagini the nagini that we know from the
harry potter films
was first introduced in the goblet of
fire where she is described as eating
the body of muggle frank bryce
after his brutal murder and from as far
back as we can remember
she's glued to voldemort's side a
trustworthy and loyal companion
through seemingly any kind of adversity
when voldemort was weak and just a
shadow of the powerful man that he
usually was
she was still there right by him and
this truly speaks to the bond that
voldemort and nagini had
however the nagini that we know from the
harry potter franchise
is not expanded upon much in the
original series
and it's not until fantastic beasts came
out that we got a little bit more of her
history
nagini is such a rich character with a
lot of history
but in harry potter we only see her in
her snake form
and the relationship that she has with
voldemort had already been developed
we don't really get a proper sense of
who she is or what her story is and in
today's video
i'm going to be diving into the history
of nagini not just the snake
but the woman nagini's birth here is not
officially recorded anywhere
but we do know that when we first see
her in fantastic beasts
it's the year 1927 and she looks to be
in her late 20s or so
with this in mind i'm going to assume
that nagini was born sometime around the
year
1900 however nagini wasn't born into
normal circumstances
she wasn't born as a normal healthy
young baby she was born with a curse
we don't know whether or not nagini came
from a family of witches
muggles or something else but we do know
that her lineage had the maledictus
curse
in its bloodline a dark curse that is
passed on through generations of family
members and has transferred
from mother to daughter because of this
nagini was born a female maledictus
one who carries the maledictus curse a
maledictus
suffers from a blood male addiction a
type of curse that causes the sufferer
to slowly transform into an animal over
the course of their life
the animal can vary according to the
specific curse
in guinea's case her blood male
addiction meant that she was destined
to turn into a snake becoming less human
and more snake
each and every day generally for quite a
number of years
the maledictus will possess the ability
to transform at will
but that's what slips over time
eventually you will lose the ability to
transform
and will be stuck in whatever animal
form that is destined for you
a blood male addiction is an awful and
inescapable curse
that eats away at you slowly stripping
away your identity
in harry potter we see nagini after she
has completely lost the ability to
transform at will
and she is permanently stuck in her
snake form however
in fantastic beasts she's still clearly
able to assume her human form
and even switches between the two before
transforming into a snake permanently
and eventually becoming a horcrux nagini
was a shy
quiet kind woman who was unfortunately
mistreated by the circus arcanus
circus arcanus was a travelling
wizarding circus owned by a man named
skender it was essentially considered to
be a freak show
and boasted the world's most complete
congress of human oddities
nagini was put on display and forced to
show the world what a freak she was
when in reality she was just a poor
woman that suffered from an awful curse
skender was incredibly cruel and
exploited nagini
forcing her to perform for his show day
in and day out
she was stuck there that is until
credence barebone came along
during one of her performances credence
came along and released fire drakes
allowing her to escape and run away with
him their new friendship was unusual
and each was as confused as the other
with regards to their place in the world
they were an uncanny pair a mistreated
maledictus that had been being held
captive
and credence a boy that knew nothing of
his identity
in an effort to help credence the two
partnered up and they sought answers
with regards to credence's existence
who were his biological parents where
was his family
after an unfortunate run-in with one of
grindelwald's acolytes
ghana grimson nagini and credence found
themselves on the top of a house
near the eiffel tower where they met to
gel at grindelwald himself
at this point in time grindelwald was
quite familiar with credence
and began planting the seeds of
manipulation knowing that the power of
this impressionable
but powerful young obscurus could be
easily swayed and harnessed if he played
his cards right
though nagini is seemingly quite evil in
harry potter
she doesn't appear to be evil at all in
fantastic beasts
in fact she immediately recognized what
grindelwald was trying to do to credence
and tried her best to save him after
surviving grindelwald's paris rally
and losing credence she eventually teams
up with the good guys
newt scamander tina goldstein jacob and
others
i'm really interested to see how nagini
makes the transition
from helpful kind woman to evil snake
and there are a lot of dots that need to
be connected in the next three fantastic
beasts films
however for now let's just resume
nakini's story
at the point at which she first
encounters lord voldemort
though we don't have an exact date it's
speculated that nagini and voldemort
met in the forests of albania sometime
in the 1980s
at this point nagini would have likely
fully assumed her snake-like form
and voldemort would have been hiding in
his disembodied state
what their initial interaction would
have looked like is anyone's guess
however we do know a couple of things
about voldemort that would have helped
him in interacting with the giant snake
first of all voldemort is the descendant
of salazar slytherin
this means that his connection to snakes
is strong and that he can even
communicate with them because of his
ability to speak
parcel tongue nagini who would have been
stuck in her maledictus form at this
point in time
would have probably leaped at the
opportunity to finally speak with
someone she was a lost
maledictus that was devoid of
communication and finally she
encountered someone who could understand
her
it was someone that she could tell her
story to whether voldemort would have
been able to recognize that she was a
maledictus or not
is unclear however he's an extremely
versed legitimate
so i'm sure he could have taken a look
inside of her mind and figured it out
at this point in time both nagini and
voldemort were a bit lost in the world
similar to when she first met credence
nagini was stuck in a snake form
an entirely new identity and was
completely devoid of human interaction
she probably had no idea what her next
move was going to be
and she must have been incredibly lonely
in voldemort's case he had just been
recently defeated
and was likely also at a bit of a loss
for what to do next
for this reason i think that it is only
natural that the two would pair and join
up
each of them having something to offer
the other without nagini
it would have been considerably more
difficult to return to a corporeal form
and without voldemort nagini would have
had no purpose in the world and no one
to talk to
she would have just been alone nagini
became instrumental in all voldemort's
survival before he could be restored to
his real body
and her venom was even used as an elixir
that helped him to survive
it was one of the primary ingredients in
a potion that he used to rebuild his
strength
nagini also helped voldemort to commit
numerous murders
and one murder in particular the murder
of bertha jorgens
sealed their bond more than ever you see
after the death of bertha jorgens
nagini became one of voldemort's
horcraxes she was now more than just the
companion of voldemort
a fragment of voldemort's soul lived
inside of her
by this point in time her previous shy
and gentle nature was no more
and she became a weapon for lord
voldemort the man to which she was
completely loyal
because she was one of voldemort's
horcruxes she even shared a telepathic
bond with him
and was able to communicate with him
over vast distances
despite voldemort's evil nature she
thought very highly of him
and i think that she only became more
and more like him as the years went by
it should also be mentioned that
voldemort thought very highly of nagini
which can't be said for a lot of people
in fact dumbledore had this to say
of voldemort's relationship with nagini
i think he is perhaps as fond of her as
he can be
of anything he certainly likes to keep
her close and has an unusual amount of
control over her
even for a parcel mouth the pair had a
special bond
and their union allowed two lost souls
to reignite their sense of purpose in
the world
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it did i miss anything about
nagini's history
if so let me know down in the comment
section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]